[Music]
three and a half thousand years ago in
Egypt a noble Pharaoh was the victim of
a violent attack but the attack was not
physical
this royal had been dead for 20 years
the attack was historical an act of
damnatio memoriae the damnation of
memory somebody smashed the Pharaohs
statues took a chisel and attempted to
erase the Pharaohs name and image from
history who was this Pharaoh and what
was behind the attack here's the key the
pharaoh Hatshepsut was a woman in the
normal course of things she should never
have been Pharaoh although it was legal
for a woman to be a monarch it disturbed
some essential Egyptian beliefs firstly
the Pharaoh was known as the living
embodiment of the male god Horus
secondly disturbance to the tradition of
rule by men was a serious challenge to
MOT a word for truth expressing a belief
in order and justice vital to the
Egyptians hot Shep suit had perhaps
tried to adapt to this belief in the
link between order and patriarchy
through her titles she took the name MOT
Kaare and sometimes referred to herself
as Hatshepsut with a masculine word
ending but apparently these efforts
didn't convince everyone and perhaps
someone erased hot Shep suits image so
that the world would forget the
disturbance to Marat and Egypt could be
balanced again hot Shep suit moreover
was not the legitimate heir to the
throne
but a regent a kind of stand-in Co
monarch the Egyptian kingship
traditionally passed from father to son
it passed from Tut mosa the first to his
son Tut most of the second hot Shep
suits husband it should have passed from
Tut Musa the second directly to his son
Tut mosa the third but Tut most of the
third was a little boy when his father
died
hot Shep suit the dead Pharaohs chief
wife and Widow stepped in to help
Azhar stepsons Regent but ended up
ruling beside him as a fully fledged
Pharaoh
perhaps Tut mosa the third was angry
about this perhaps he was the one who
erased her images it's also possible
that someone wanted to dishonor HUD chef
suit because she was a bad Pharaoh but
the evidence suggests she was actually
pretty good
she competently fulfilled their
traditional roles of the office she was
a great builder her mortuary temple
Giselle Giselle was an architectural
phenomenon at the time and is still
admired today she enhanced the economy
of Egypt conducting a very successful
trade mission to the distant Land of
Punt
she had strong religious connections she
even claimed to be the daughter of the
state god Amun and she had a successful
military career with a nubian campaign
and claims she fought alongside her
soldiers in battle of course we have to
be careful when we assess the success of
hot chef suits career since most of the
evidence was written by hot Shep suit
herself she tells her own story in
pictures and writing on the walls of her
mortuary temple and the red Chapel she
built for Amun so who committed the
crimes against Hut chef suits memory the
most popular suspect is her stepson
nephew and co-ruler Tut most of the
third did he do it out of anger because
she stole his throne this is unlikely
since the damage wasn't done until 20
years after how Shep suit died that's a
long time to hang on to anger and then
act in a rage maybe Tut most of the
third did it to make his own reign look
stronger but it is most likely that he
or someone else erased the images so
that people would forget that a woman
ever sat on Egypt's throne this gender
anomaly was simply too much of a threat
to Murat and had to be obliterated from
history happily the ancient censors were
not quite thorough enough enough
evidence survived for us to piece
together what happened so the story of
this unique powerful woman can now be
told
[Music]